did you know that there's been a hidden
QR code in every episode of She-Hulk
continuing the tradition of hiding these
scannable codes in every Disney plus
Marvel series each episode features a QR
code that when scanned will lead to a
free copy of a She-Hulk comic book let's
break down where exactly you can find
these codes throughout the series and
how each free comic relates to the
episode
[Music]
the first episode of She-Hulk attorney
at law features a QR code tying into her
first Marvel Comics appearance Savage
She-Hulk Number One released in 1980.
the QR code appears at the 617 timestamp
as Jen enters a bar from its back
entrance on a small poster with the
words ladies night above is a scannable
code which will take you to the Marva
website in this Debut Issue Dr Bruce
Banner visits his cousin Jennifer
Walters a practicing lawyer in Los
Angeles where he tells her that he's the
Incredible Hulk Walters in exchange
reveals that the client she's
representing had been framed for murder
which leads to her being shot Banner
tries to save her life by donating his
blood but in doing so she gained similar
powers to that of her cousin becoming
another gamma-powered Hulk the parallels
between the comic book version and the
MCU origin are quite similar but instead
of a shooting incident the MCU gives us
a car accident which resulted in
Banner's blood coming in contact with
Walters resulting in her newly acquired
abilities
foreign
[Music]
episode provided us with a QR code
pretty early on after her significant
courtroom reveal and adopting the
moniker of She-Hulk Jen gets fired from
her Law Firm at the 555 timestamp as
she's exploring new job opportunities
online the QR code appears beside the
post title 10 offbeat jobs for a fresh
start this code redirects audiences
again to the Marvel website where you
can read a free copy of She-Hulk Number
One released in 2004. this comic run
centers around Jennifer Walters who
undergoes a personal and professional
transformation as she juggles being a
practicing lawyer and being She-Hulk It
ultimately costs her job due to
obligations as an Avenger but not for
very long when her former boss Holden
Holloway rehires her but as Jennifer
Walters rather than a She-Hulk the
opposite of what we saw in the episode
where she's named as the head of the
Superhuman law division only as She-Hulk
we are the first top tier Law Firm to
launch an entire division dedicated to
superhuman law God is this why they
hired me in the third episode we're
introduced tube the ongoing issue of a
former colleague of Jennifer Walters
Dennis Bakowski being defrauded by a
light L from new Asgard who has
impersonated Grammy award-winning
recording artist Megan thee stallion the
QR code appeared at the 820 timestamp
when Augustus pug puglies returned to
his laptop following a briefing as he
reviews the footage of the incident on
you screen an Indiscreet YouTube
off-brand the QR code appears below the
video alongside a video review of a pair
of Iron Man 3 sneakers scanning the code
redirects you to the Marvel website
where you can read a free copy of savage
She-Hulk number two this issue provides
a glimpse into Dennis bakowski's
personality who like his counterpart in
the Disney plus series is pretty
antagonistic towards Walters well to be
fair I thought I was dating Megan the
stallion sorry what sorry you thought
you were dating Megan the style the
fourth QR code has proven to be the
trickiest to find but it can be found
around the 552 timestamp on Jen's dating
profile page this code would lead you to
a free copy of the West Coast Avengers
annual number four released in 1986
featuring Andromeda dagger Invisible
Woman Jean Gray Scarlet Witch storm and
She-Hulk on its cover it's likely that
this issue was included to point toward
the seven women featured in the previous
episode as the soulmates of Emil Blonsky
because this comic is actually subtitled
gather now ye7 Brides
love you in the fifth episode audiences
followed Nikki and Pug's Antics to a
boba shop in Los Angeles in pursuit of
the Iron Man 3 sneakers upon entering
the store the QR code can be seen at the
652 timestamp stuck to the wall just
below a picture and scanning it will
lead you to a free copy of She-Hulk
number 10. this comic showcases
she-hulk's archenemesis Titania which is
quite fitting since she faces off
against Titania in this episode of the
Disney plus series as well luckily jyn
was able to put her Feud with Titania to
the side as we were finally teased with
the arrival of Matt Murdoch or Daredevil
towards the end of the episode thanks to
a familiar looking piece of headgear in
Luke Jacobson Studio Tinsley does client
confidentiality mean nothing to you
in the sixth episode the QR code can be
spotted after we're introduced to Craig
Hollis this time around the 741
timestamp the code appears on the side
skirt of a car crushed by Hollis or Mr
Immortal after he jumped out of the law
office's window the Free Comic behind
the QR code is the West Coast Avengers
number 46 which sees Mr Immortal make
his comic debut and it's pretty
befitting that one of the episode's
eclectic characters gets his comic book
linked to the QR code also this episode
Bears similarities to the comic book
issue as the West Coast Avengers have to
deal with someone using the Avengers
name without consent just like Titania
using the She-Hulk name without
permission
nice suit Shrek
all right most viewers missed the
seventh episode's QR code which can be
found during Josh and Jen's date at the
228 timestamp if you look between the
food truck's patrons you can find the
code posing as a sticker on the truck
scanning the code redirects you to the
Marvel website and the next free comic
available to read is Tales to astonish
number 48. this comic introduces the
porcupine who fights Ant-Man and the
WASP the same smelly character featured
in the episode during the therapy
session at Emile blonsky's retreat
[Music]
in the eighth episode we find ourselves
at leapfrog's secret lair the lily pad
if you navigate to the 1711 timestamp
and look for a wooden pole with a notice
attached to it you can find the eighth
QR code once you've scanned the code a
free copy of She-Hulk number nine is
available to read this issue showcases
the trial of the century as Jen goes one
on one against Matt Murdoch in an
intense courtroom battle much like the
one audiences were treated to in this
episode of She-Hulk
no I didn't he's lying don't ask me how
I know I just know yes we can all tell
his lie Mr Murdoch the final QR code
from She-Hulk attorney at law can be
found when She-Hulk exits her own show
and filters behind the scenes via the
Disney plus menu now She-Hulk walks into
the studio car park at timestamp 1715.
we see her approach a white door that
says She-Hulk attorney at law production
and the QR code is on the left hand side
of the sign the final code was a
relatively easy one to spot which is
surprising considering everything else
that was unfolding around the hunt and
now it's time to take our final trip
back to marvel.com in order to read the
last free comic offered from the studio
The Sensational She-Hulk number 50 first
published in April 1993 and written by
Frank Miller and his team Sensational
She-Hulk number 50 breaks the fourth
ball in spectacular style after she
finds out writer John Byrne has died and
sets out to find a new writing team for
her series the finale of the Disney Plus
show definitely took inspiration from
this style with a very meta fourth wall
break the issue is another meta Escapade
led by She-Hulk and features various
first and only appearance says by a
range of character variants including
British Spider-Man Popeye Thanos and
fantasy She-Hulk
what kind of stupid finale is this this
final fourth wall brick was done in a
really creative way and I think it's
great that Marvel's been hiding these
Easter eggs like the QR codes throughout
each series but I'd like to know what
you think what's your favorite Easter
egg you found in She-Hulk drop your
thoughts in the comment section below
also check out the video on your screen
for some more of my content don't forget
to like And subscribe and thanks for
watching Rocket Riley
foreign